vous êtes monsieur gad elmaleh qu'est ce
que je peux qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
que l'on en connaisse rose loi qui mette
la photo
oui ça va mon gars oui bonjour gardes tu
m'appelles gardes tu sais que tout le
monde attendait et on appelle brigade
oui
frérot tu sais que grâce à toi va tous
aller dormir chez quelqu'un semaine
prochaine non sur alors là je vais dire
tu veux que je dise quelque chose
qu'est-ce qui se passe est ce que tu
veux que je dise cad tu veux que je lève
le bras sont comme ceux ci qu'est ce que
tu veux que je fasse deux regarde ce que
je crains c'est bon bah tu es chez toi
qu est ce qu a faire ses frères sur ma
bi les les yeux deux frères on dirait
que tu viens de voir tes résultats du
bac et sortent à vue gad elmaleh non
refusé journal baba pas 44 points à
rattraper je voulais te lire chez moi
tout seul je te regardais la télé et
quand j'ai entendu le défi je vais
tacler tu as un amour très haute à vue
qu'elle s'embarque cette attitude on
veut parler qui dit avoir cela passe
petit intermède musical
vous avez demandé qu eddie le quitter
parce que le son téléphone en train
c'est pas la même chose que l'image nous
a fait un sacré décalage
boxe et 10 secondes
alors est ce que tu peux parler qui lie
à l'antenne mort antenne à l'antenne
d'accord tenez on n'a rien à cacher mais
afrique alors allie musique
alors attendez avait demandé à hervé
lassalle a fait seul ça va nous coûter
d'assassins ces conneries week a dit à
logan c'était couette
tranquille c'était en mai gad ce que
j'ouvre alors regarde ce que je te
propose parce que tu sais que moi j'ai
une émission à terre j'ai des chiffres
qui tombent tout laisse un vide
je vais pas te mentir toi dieu bénisse
ta carrière va très bien moi j'ai le csa
qui est sur nous donc ce que je vais te
proposent ils
je vais donner mon portable à kelly et
elle va partir mon salon privé de pas
d'accord ok tu pars en salles aux brides
et accompagné de mon mobile et on se
récupère d'un sommet mais les catalans
canada québec qui me parle et vous
passez un salon privé pas à aller
s'asseoir en classe ils saluent brigade
merci battu peu pâle un peu plus loin
merci passe